le geste est pathétique
l'heure est historique le champion du
monde d'échecs vient d'être battu en
combat très singulier par une machine il
était certain pourtant d'en venir à bout
cependant l'intelligence a dû laisser
place à la formidable puissance de
calcul stockés dans les laboratoires du
bm est implanté dans les entrailles d'un
ordinateur d'une tonne et demie doté
d'une logistique et d'un centre de
recherche aux moyens quasi illimités
l'homme après avoir tâtonné douter
souffert n'avait plus que la sixième
partie pour prouver sa supériorité
il s'est incliné et ça n'est pas dans
ses habitudes
l'ogre de bakou d'ordinaire impassible a
dû aller jusqu'au bout de l'humiliation
il conteste à présent l'impartialité du
match pour lui les dés ont pu être pipés
je pense qu'il est temps pour deep blue
de jouer au vrai échec et je peux vous
promettre à vous tous que si deep blue
joue à la régulière je vous le garantis
je le réduis en pièces